olá boa noite
eu me apresentar eu sou maurício vidal
montenegro hoje eu sou diretor regional
de um grupo internacional de educação
hoje eu respondo por cinco instituições
em três estados diferentes são 23 mil
estudantes e quase 2 mil colegas
além disso também foi membro do ad que é
um grupo que promove o avanço de
mulheres em cargos de liderança dentro
da nossa organização ea parte mais
importante sobre mim é que eu sou mãe
das gêmeas adele manuela de 9 anos
esposa já começa a chorar
sua esposa não tão dedicada de um marido
extremamente delicado que uma pessoa
super importante que suporta que me
apoia na minha carreira e uma pessoa sem
a qual eu não estaria aqui hoje de
primata astronauta no filme 2001
odisseia no espaço tem 16 todo mundo
assistiu a uma cena e que os homens em
estágio ainda primata da escola descobre
no osso uma uma ferramenta de ataque
contra as tribos rivais né estão
apavorados com o poder da ferramenta por
que eles ferem e matam com ela
eles jogam um é o osso para o céu e de
repente a cena corta a cena corta pela
nave espacial não assistir a esse filme
ainda ainda criança e depois assistir
muitas vezes é na idade adulta mas eu
confesso que não consegui entender se
esse salto é como é que ia de primata
para astronauta então curiosamente no
ano de 2001 no âmbito do mestrado
o professor me apresentou o conceito de
tecnologia o que é tecnologia tecnologia
é a filosofia dos fins do propósito dos
objetivos
então toda a história todo o processo da
humanidade ea realidade de cada um de
nós pode ser explicada como a trajetória
rumo a uma finalidade causa e efeito
então eu entendi a cena
é totalmente ficou claro que sim
a descoberta da ferramenta pelo homem
jamais teríamos e do espaço já era
jamais teríamos chegado a a a tecnologia
espacial
então isso só abriu minha mente eu
fiquei eu fiquei eu fiquei fascinada
então comecei a analisar essas coisas
dentro da minha vida porque acho que na
maioria das vezes a gente não tenha
compreensão de como as decisões dos
momentos eles impactam na nossa
realidade eles impactam é na vida de
outras pessoas
então passei a fazer essa análise sobre
mim né quais eram os pontos quais eram
as trajetórias quais eram os caminhos
que tinham trazido até aqui
então trago três deles aqui para
compartilhar com vocês e trago estes
porque eu sei que a gente vai encontrá
los em qualquer uma em qualquer pessoa
talvez na vida de cada um de vocês e
espero que eles possam inspirar los para
que vocês possam é superar na carreira
de vocês
o primeiro ponto é aprender e eu eu
nasci numa família de agricultores cna
analfabetas do sertão da paraíba
vendo que que não havia muito futuro né
pra família lá meus pais decidiram e
morar em outra cidade e foi morar na
cidade de esperança nome bem apropriado
da esperança uma cidade ainda na no
interior da paraíba chegando lá meu pai
nasceu uma vida diferente e se mantém
como o mobral movimento brasileiro de
alfabetização
quando estava com quatro anos ele
começou a me alfabetizar né com que ele
tinha aprendido no mobral então eu
aprendi a ler antes de ir para a escola
e descobrir a leitura descobriu
aprendizado foi impacto devastador na
minha vida então passei a ler todos os
livros danificados o dia livre
obviamente nem eu passei aí na
biblioteca municipal eu passei a ler
todos os livros que eu podia
eu li dos clássicos infantis
os aniversários a física ea matemática
claro astronomia e aí aprender né
saber que eu posso aprender saber que o
aprendizado é um processo contínuo e
saber que eu podia aprender qualquer
coisa é uma das coisas é um momento osso
que me trouxe até aqui
segundo ponto de educação de qualidade
quando estava com 12 anos
meus pais resolveram mudar de novo então
fomos morar no campina grande nos anos
80 haviam sido anos de de muita seca é a
vida de diferentes já não suportava mais
é financeiramente a nossa família que
agora já estava com sete filhos sendo o
eu
a mais velha não chegando em campina
grande iniciamos um pequeno negócio de
fabricação de doces e salgados né e
pastéis coxinhas sonhos ea gente
entregava essas coisas essencialmente
nas cantinas das escolas privadas da
cidade
e aí meus irmãos e eu a gente e entregar
isso né
nas escolas privadas ea gente chegava
mais ou menos na hora do recreio quando
a gente chegava na hora do recreio de
ver todas aquelas estruturas daquela
escola aquelas que a criança de classe
média alta com suas fardas mochilas
tênis bonitas e olhava em contraste
quando os nossos sandália de dedo roupas
torradas
aí eu entendi que não tava tendo as
mesmas oportunidades que não tava certo
eu precisava ter acesso aquilo pra ter
um papel um destino diferente então sim
comecei a incomodar meu pai em oitavo
eu preciso estudar numa escola dessa eu
preciso ter acesso a esse tipo de
educação mas obviamente a aas finanças
da minha família não não comportavam e
meu pai começou a falar na escola a
gente tenha acesso aos diretores né
olha só que não consegui uma bolsa pra
minha filha ea gente ouvia coisas do
tipo não
genival e sancha ajuda pra você não está
pra você não recebe o oriental para
voltar pra escola pública que era onde a
gente estava estudando mas em algum
momento meu pai conseguiu sensibilizar o
diretor de uma escola super tradicional
de campina grande e conseguiu que
ajudassem ensino médio lá mas é mas
tinha um prato saboroso trata o trato
era gente trocar os sonhos recheado de
goiaba que a gente fazia pelo meu sonho
ele ter acesso à educação de qualidade
tanto legal
esse foi o fim do ensino médio lá como
era uma boa leitora passei voando as
minhas redações sempre eram lidas em
falar de aula e nos 16 anos para ser
vestibular pra federal da paraíba e foi
aprovada passando assim se a primeira
pessoa da minha família tem acesso ao
ensino superior
depois disso na na faculdade pop leve
pela faculdade dada a situação era sobe
para 65 anos lá quando terminei a
faculdade anunciação
fiquei meio perdida não sabia muito
ainda o que fazer e aí a minha irmã
número 2 marilene sunset é bom no geral
estava fazendo a seleção para o mestrado
de economia porque ela tinha acabado de
concluir a segunda pessoa a concluir o
curso economia então ela disse olha você
não faz um mestrado então eu fiquei
muito na dúvida é ter um mestrado em
economia não era minha área não tinha
certeza
mas ela disse os cinco primeiros
colocados recebem uma bolsa da capes
cifrões piscar no meu olho e isso é
motivador sendo que não era um mestrado
em economia era um mestrado em economia
política ela nos mestrados mais
concorridos do brasil vinha gente de
todas as partes do país prestou a
seleção pra ele mas aprender um ponto
definidor para próprias pessoas
então peguei a bibliografia
é e amanda bibliografia os seguintes
volumes de karl max do capital
a riqueza das nações de adam smith os
princípios políticos do df ricardo era
assustador mas eu leio eu aprendo eu
aprendo lendo tal comecei a me preparar
para a prova tempo era curto e aí chegou
o dia da prova no dia do meu aniversário
chego lá o auditório como esse lotado de
candidatos entre o centro faz a minha
prova
um ano depois terminar a prova vai
descendo a escada do auditório irmão
olha pra mim acho que ela pensou que
entrega prova em branco de se entregar a
prova tem primeiro que todo mundo e aí
depois a gente passou pelas pelos
processos de projeto de entrevista e aí
fomos aprovadas as duas não só fomos
aprovados ficam entre as cinco primeiras
colocadas
pegamos abusa e passamos dois anos no
mestrado
então ter tido acesso a esse tipo de
informação de educação educação de
qualidade no ensino médio
na faculdade de administração no
mestrado
isso me trouxe até aqui hoje esse é um
ponto ou outro momento osso na minha
vida
3º 3º aproveitar a oportunidade estava
finalizando mestrado
já comecei a tentar inserir no mercado
de trabalho então passei a enviar
currículos para a faculdade
buscando uma vaga de professor de
economia sendo que a gente soube que a
tábua uma faculdade em caruaru
então vamos lá mesmo e eu vamos lá
entregar o currículo para lecionar no
curso de economia
mas conversando lá com pessoal com os
diretores ser óleo com economia vai
demorar demais três anos ainda não está
autorizado pelo ministério da educação
você tem desde o currículo aí depois a
gente te chama
mas também descobriu que o curso de
animação já estava provado que as aulas
iriam iniciar em setembro
minha formação da anunciação então
perguntei o diretor
olha minha formação e mission santo ea
melhora da economia não tem vaga para
professor aqui
durante a ação eles não todas as vagas
já estão preenchidas
fiquei meio triste em ver assim ele lá
dentro mas você você tem mestrado em
economia só foi lançando chance é tem
vaga de coordenador de curso você quer
sim ele nunca me viu nunca vi ele
aí olhei para minha irmã me uma vez é
claro aceitei
agarrei a oportunidade do primeiro
emprego peguei pra mim só que não sabia
nada de coordenação de curso não sabia
nada de gestão de ensino superior fazia
idéia de como fazer isso mas eu aprendo
eu tive uma boa formação que tinha que
aproveitar aquela oportunidade e assim
foi
aproveitei e e iniciei o meu trabalho na
instituição então se especificamente no
dia 11 de setembro de 2001 dia que mudou
a história da economia política mundial
eu estava lá me apresentando como
coordenadora do uso de anexação dessa
instituição e que conhecia seu moço que
venha ser o meu marido depois
coincidência
não claro não acredito em coincidências
tecnologia teleologia trajetória que
leva a uma finalidade foram coisas que
me trouxeram até aqui hoje é esse e se
essa instituição é um centro
universitário conta com 10.000 alguns e
2012 foi adquirido por um grupo
internacional no qual eu faço parte hoje
então
eu costumo dizer o seguinte que para
quem deveria estar sob o sol do sertão
capina do mato semi-analfabeta com as
sete crianças pequenas
estou eu hoje aqui no tb
ex-diretora-executiva de um grupo
internacional aconteceu comigo igual o
que aconteceu com o filme sai de primata
achou na alta essa analogia
obrigada
[Aplausos]